Rico you ready to go I'm ready to go all
right three two one go
[Music]
me and five my coworkers are going to
make a ginormous GPS drawing of a whale
across the city of New York
Oh shake now to make this light I'm
going to be the navigator and my friends
are going to be passing the GPS baton
from one to the other but Todd each of
us is gonna be running seven miles we're
doing a 35 mile whale I don't know if
I'm gonna make it to be honest you go
from Hudson to canal you go down to six
turn right on Thomas you're gonna get
onto Broadway that's cute that's to make
sex you're doing means I can't you're
going to pop on the Brooklyn Bridge it
is completely free me there's no
visibility
I think it's hailing I can't feel it
[Music]
it's so cold every time I started
running it just starts raining harder
I'm surprised this phone is holding up I
know it's waterproof in case you ever
needed run in the rain so you're coming
up to Broadway and then there's Lois you
got [ __ ] you got [ __ ] gosh I'm kind of
unclear exactly what I've got myself
into to be honest freako
yo okay are you ready it's raining all
right well you owe me a you only have 7
miles to go so high that don't mind me
nothing to see here
hello but they poured it until you here
Johnson but Porsche is taking the entire
warehouse right now yeah I know it looks
like it's taking your warehouse but it's
not your fight oh hi Jed I actually just
I'm not joking I went into a shipping
container just then okay it's okay
you're gonna go just like down Porter
until you hit Johnson can you stop
saying hit it's okay have you passed
Gratton and just crossing it now turn
now turn back around
are you joking now you have to double
back oh my god right now and then you're
gonna take a ride on really crappy
recover okay
[Music]
[Applause]
it's perfect the weather today is
perfect we probably want to pick up the
pace a little bit okay
do you jobs like on the regular not
usually while I'm on the phone we've
already drawn the tail you've drawn the
bottom Luis drew the fins and now you're
drawing kind of like the head JJ is up
on Roosevelt just chuck it all the way
over there you're almost there
there you go JJ I have a baton I've
never run seven miles in my entire life
so this would be an interesting
experience for me basically like the
next rate you're gonna seems like 57th
Street okay I just crossed over 57
what's the area like um can we video
chat yeah this is cool I've never been
to this part of town before I've also
never had my life in someone else's
hands
pigeon how are your legs holding up my
legs are pretty sore from the one-block
test run every day yesterday we got a
rub the fatigue out of them feel like
ridiculously close I've run marathons
but this is the weirdest thing I have
ever done Aileen we are almost there I
go a Greenpoint Williamsburg yeah so
there's something very nice on the other
end of the rainbow for you yeah it's
called a beer you're getting into
hipster territory and no one's looking
at me cuz they are too cool
well I'm up there I'm a bear I like that
turning light
we're doing it yes
yes
[Music]
maybe didn't know but the painter
splines yes all your pizza
[Music]